- Hello, welcome to our
daily homeroom live stream.
For those of you all this
is your first time coming,
this is something that we started doing
when we started seeing school
closures around the world.
Khan Academy, we are not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
Obviously a big part of
that is we've been creating
learning materials, software, videos,
all free, all not commercial.
And as soon as we saw the
school closures happening,
we said we have to make
this as usable as possible
for teachers, parents, and students
so that everyone can keep learning.
So that's when we started
publishing schedules,
putting out learning plans,
parent and teacher webinars,
and we also thought, in a
time of social distancing,
wouldn't it be nice if there was a place
where we could connect in
a, I guess you could say,
synchronous way, where we
could have conversations,
answer each other's questions,
bring on interesting guests.
And that's what this live stream is for.
And now before we get in to
the meat of the live stream,
and the meat of today's live stream
will be around Giving Tuesday.
There's actually a lot of things going on.
It's National Teacher Appreciation Week.
We'll talk a little bit about that.
But it's also Giving Tuesday.
But in line with Giving Tuesday,
I do wanna remind everyone, again,
we are not for profit.
And the only way we're
able to do our work,
for it to be free, for
it to be non commercial.
A lot of people come to Khan Academy
and they think there's a catch.
Clearly there's a lot of
resources being put into it.
Are they going to try to sell
me something at some point?
The reason why we don't,
and we never intend to
is because we're supported
with philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself,
and we'll talk a lot
about that over the course
of today's conversation.
But I do wanna give special thanks
to several corporations
that have stepped up
in recent weeks when they found out
that we were already running at a deficit
before the COVID crisis,
and now in the crisis
with our traffic being two to three X
of what it typically is, and
we're trying to accelerate
all of these programs to
figure out better ways
to support parents,
teachers, and students.
Bank of America, Google.org, AT&T,
Novartis, and fastly all stepped up,
literally in a matter of days,
to make sure that we have less of a gap.
But we still need more help.
I wanna make it very clear.
Khan Academy is much more than just me.
There's 200 full-time
teachers, researchers,
engineers, designers, managers,
who are bringing Khan Academy to you
and because of that we're able to serve,
we have over 100 million registered users.
There's 10s of millions
of learners who come
on a monthly basis.
And that's only possible with
financial support donations.
So given that today is Giving Tuesday,
that's going to be the focus of this,
but this will be a two-way exchange.
I am going to try to convince you,
if you're in a position.
I don't wanna guilt you if
you're not in a position
to do so, but every dollar matters.
But if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
And in return, the main thing in return,
all of us at Khan Academy
are going to be able
to do our work and hopefully
serve you and many millions
of students around the world.
But I'm also happy to answer any questions
that you might have about anything.
So this is a true ask me anything.
And so whether you're watching on Facebook
or on YouTube, put your
questions in the message boards.
Myself and some team members,
we're gonna be looking at that
and as long as it's decent
and nothing is out of bounds.
I'm happy to answer any question.
So while we're waiting
for questions to come in,
I'm just going to, we have
some goals with our team.
We're hoping to get 20,000 donations.
We care about the number
of people donating
because that shows that
there's other people
in this boat with us.
There's other people
around the world who care
about this mission of
free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
Even if they're donating three dollars.
That makes a difference, and
it's a huge show of support
for the work that we're doing.
Our goal is to raise $50,000
on YouTube in the month of May,
and $25,000 on Facebook this week.
If you look, I believe it's on my left,
I think I'm pointing in the right place,
you will see donate
buttons, either on Facebook
or YouTube where you'll have
an opportunity to donate.
Once again, if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about doing that.
And I will read some quick testimonials
just to give a sense of,
a flavor of how people
are using Khan Academy right now.
This is the type of thing
that gives us energy
and I hope all of you
all, if you view yourself
as part of the Khan Academy
community, which I hope you do,
especially if you're a supporter,
that you take satisfaction
in things like this.
This is a thing we got recently.
This here is a quote from
a physician, actually.
I'm a resident physician in New York.
We've been working long, hard
days with COVID patients.
I'm writing to say thank you.
I used your early materials to get through
my undergraduate and medical education.
My two and a half year old has been home
due to school closures
and I haven't had a chance
to see her much in the last few weeks.
I came home today and she said,
let's sing the Khan Academy song
in regards to a song that has
helped her learn to count.
Your educational programs
carried me through my education
and are now teaching my
young daughter, thank you.
That's John, and so first of all,
John, if you're listening
or maybe you'll watch
the recording of this later,
thank you so much for that.
One, the work you're doing.
Medical workers are genuinely
on the front line of this war,
whatever you wanna call it, against COVID,
so thank you for doing that work.
And it makes us incredibly happy
and incredibly proud that
not only were we able
to be part of your education.
So in our way by us
helping you many years ago,
maybe you're going to be able to help
that many more people with COVID.
But also in this time of need,
and I'm sure your family needs support
and your family's going
through a lot of stress,
it's our honor to be able
to support your daughter
through her learning.
And for those of you who don't know,
Khan Academy Kids, I had Caroline over,
who's the founder of Khan Academy Kids
last Friday on the live stream.
I can't speak highly
enough how cool it is.
I have a five and a half year old.
They just added first grade content.
They also just added teacher tools,
so teachers can make assignments and see
what students have completed.
And it starts as early as ages two.
It goes up to ages seven.
And I really think that
is, it's a math, reading,
writing, social emotional urging.
It even has stuff on logic.
It covers all of the
standards that can be covered
in that format.
I encourage parents or
anyone in your family
who might have an early learner
to check that out.
And that's the type of
work that we're able to do
with this support.
This all to cost resources,
and whether it's the core Khan Academy
that many of you all are familiar with
or Khan Academy Kids, it's your donations
that allow us to build that, support that,
support 10s of millions
of users every month.
And to continue to improve on that.
So let's see.
We have questions here.
One from Instagram, Sarah
Hellisleesleepy, I think.
What motivated you to build Khan Academy?
So I've told this story a little bit,
but I'll tell it again in a fast form.
I was tutoring cousins back in 2004.
My day job, I was an analyst
at an investment firm.
And I just saw that maybe
there was some tools
that I could help build
that will help family.
So that's where I started
writing the exercise platform.
A very early version of it.
For my cousins to get practice, feedback.
For me as their teacher or their tutor
to keep track of what they were doing.
And then a few years
later a friend suggested,
hey why don't you make video lessons
to supplement this software
thing you're making.
And I initially thought
it was a horrible idea.
And I was, cats playing piano.
YouTube, it's not for serious math.
But I got over the idea.
It wasn't my idea, and I gave it a shot.
And long story short, I
made it for my family,
but it soon became clear that people
who are not my family were watching.
And by 2008, I said this
could be a real thing,
and that's where I
incorporated Khan Academy
as a not for profit.
And for those of you who don't know
what a not for profit is, it
means no one owns Khan Academy.
It is a public charity.
I do not own Khan Academy.
Or another way to think about it, you own
as much of Khan Academy as I do.
I do get a salary from Khan Academy.
All of our team members get
salaries from Khan Academy.
But we are employees of this organization.
It's governed by a board,
and that board, it's in the
for profit organization,
the board is, how do we
maximize shareholder value?
In a not for profit board, the board says,
how do we maximize impact.
Especially impact
aligned with our mission,
which is a free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
And by 2009, I was
hoping at first to set up
as a not for profit, maybe
some friends would volunteer
to help me out.
But by 2009, I had trouble
focusing on my day job.
My first child was just born.
My wife was a medical
resident, so we're making
a little bit of money, but
I decided to quit my job
and we lived off of savings.
We were digging in to our
savings, about $5,000 a month.
Just under the belief
that this needed to exist
in the world.
Back then there was about
100,000 people using Khan Academy
on a monthly basis.
And I used to say, who knows?
Maybe one day it'll be a
million, 10 million, 100 million.
And at the time those seemed
like delusional ideas,
but those are now true.
And I think of the opportunity and I said,
maybe one day billions
could learn from this.
And imagine if future generations,
they don't view education
as something that only
the affluent have or
only certain people have.
But they say as long as I have at least
a low-cost smartphone, I can have access
to the world's best material.
I have practice, I have feedback,
and I can learn everything
from early learning and math,
reading, writing, all
the way through the core
of elementary, middle,
high school, college.
Not just in math, not just in ELA,
but the social sciences, the sciences,
and eventually plug in to the world.
Imagine if we could
create a world like that.
And so that was the hope of Khan Academy.
That's why it was a not for profit.
And that's why, I hope,
that you're also excited
about that type of a
vision of what we can do
for the world together.
I hope one day all of you are
able to tell your children
or your grandchildren,
yeah there was a time
where free world class
education wasn't a thing.
What zip code you were born in
or how much your family
made, that was the biggest
predictor of what you're
going to do in your life,
which unfortunately, it
is the case right now.
But we think we can change that,
and empower everyone.
And that will not only
level the playing field,
but think about how many Marie
Curies or Albert Einsteins,
for every one that we discover,
how many go undiscovered?
Think about all of the
work that those kids,
who might be living in a
slum some place in India
right now, if they're able
to tap into their potential,
what they might be able to do for us.
They might find the vaccine
for the next pandemic,
a cure for a disease,
write the next great novel,
solve existential problems for humanity.
So that's kind of the
dream of Khan Academy
and how I got started.
Let's see, we have more questions here.
From Instagram, @sarah.girl2020 saying,
I'm having trouble staying focused
on my online classes.
How can I be a little bit better?
Good question, Sarah.
I'll tell you.
Well there's a couple
things that I've been doing.
One is love to keep moving.
So you can imagine I
sit in a lot of meetings
these days, and now they're
ll over Zoom and Google Meet
and whatever else.
What I've been doing,
is actually I've been
doing them while walking.
And you'll be surprised, I'm surprised.
You can be on a phone in a Zoom meeting
and you can still see the
screen and see what's going on.
I find if I'm just in a park,
ideally you're in some place
where there's not any traffic,
so you can't get hit by a car.
But I go to my local park
and I just keep doing laps
while I'm in the meeting.
And I find that that
helps me stay focused.
It gives me exercise.
I get fresh air, which
is especially important
in this time of social distancing.
So if you're lucky enough
to have a safe environment
to walk in, I think that's another thing.
I think a lot of educators
are trying to figure
things out right now.
So I think if you give
constructive feedback,
saying, hey, teacher,
that was a great session.
I really appreciate it,
but I would love to see
even more interactivity.
I would love ways, there's
ways that we can participate.
You can ask us questions.
I think a lot of educators
would welcome that.
They want you to participate more.
So that's another way
to stay really engaged.
In general, whether
it's online or off line
or just work you have to
do and there's something
called a Pomodoro Technique,
which we've talked about before.
It's named after, a Pomodoro
is a type of tomato,
but it's named after a
timer that was shaped
like a Pomodoro tomato.
The general idea is you
give yourself 20 minutes,
30 minutes, you put it
on the timer and you say,
okay, over that time, I'm
gonna work on whatever it is.
And then when that timer rings,
you give yourself a 10 minute break.
10 minutes to take a walk,
do some jumping jacks,
dance a little bit.
Whatever, and then get back to work.
And by doing it in those sessions,
you might think that 10 minutes
is kind of a waste of time
where you're taking a break, but it's not.
You're rejuvenating and
it'll give you more energy
to then focus and go deep
on whatever you're trying to work on.
So more testimonials.
And I actually wanna give
a shout out to thank yous
on several of the donations.
Elliot H., on YouTube, thank
you so much for your donation.
Sjwetel, if I'm reading
your username correctly.
Thank you so much.
Just donated $100 on YouTube.
Thank so much Sjwetel, and Sjwetel writes,
thank you Sal and
everyone at Khan Academy.
It's a noble cause.
The more knowledge we all have,
the more humane we become.
And I apologize if I'm not
pronouncing your name correctly,
or your username: sjwetel or shwetel.
Couldn't agree with you
more and I will emphasize,
I get a disproportionate amount
of credit for Khan Academy.
There's 200 plus full-time folks.
About five or six of them are
actually behind the scenes
right now, supporting this live stream.
And beyond that, we have
thousands of volunteers
around the world.
And that show of confidence
through that donation
makes a huge difference.
And that donation is going
to make a huge difference.
There's this framework
that this foundation,
the Robin Hood Foundation,
which focuses on New York,
but it's a framework
that they came up with
for calculating something
called social benefit
to cost ratio.
In the for profit world,
you look at something called
return on investment, where you say, hey,
if I invest $100 and I get $30 more,
and I get my $100 back, that's
a 30% return on investment.
And so in my hedge fund
world, we're all back
in the hedge fund days, I
would always think about,
okay where we are we gonna
get the best financial return?
Well in the not for profit world,
where are you gonna get
the best impact return?
How much impact for your dollar?
And it's generally good
if you're able to get
even a two to one impact to dollar ratio.
So there's a social impact of two.
And you say how do you
measure social impact?
Well you could say, if
someone's able to improve
their academic standing by x amount,
how would that affect
their lifetime earnings?
How much will that decrease
costs in other parts of society?
Education is inversely
correlated with how much
you have to imprison people and crime,
and all of these other things.
And then there's tax revenues that you get
the more educated people get.
And so using proxies like that,
a very good social return
is about a 10 to one.
Social benefit to cost ratios,
10 to one is a great one.
If you look at Khan Academy
and there's actually a video.
I'm happy to share it, but it's a video
where I do that back of
the envelope calculation.
You'll see Khan Academy,
you get some place
between, actually,
pre-COVID, some place between
a 250 to 400 to one ration.
And post-COVID, now
that our usage is about
two x, three x of what it typically is,
those numbers go up by two, three x.
So you're talking about in
a world where good social
benefit to cost ratio is two to one,
three to one, we're talking
about a social benefit
to cost ratio which is like 500 to one.
So for anyone donating even that dollar,
you should feel very good about that.
Even that one dollar.
That's going to drive learning
for someone on the planet,
probably someone who
doesn't have a dollar,
to learn for a good amount of time.
If I remember the numbers correctly,
our cost of delivering learning
is around 15 cents per hour.
So even that dollar is able
to impact a lot of people.
That $100 that you gave,
Sjwetel, there's gonna be a lot
of people that are gonna be
empowered because of that.
So thank you so much for it.
So I have more testimonials here.
So this is from Heather, who's a parent.
Heather writes, I've been
using Khan Academy for six
of my children since the
onset of COVID-19 pandemic.
I would have used it sooner
had I known it was available
free of charge.
Please donate if you can.
It's truly beneficial to
families, especially now.
Well thank you Heather
and we agree with you.
One of the things, donate,
that would be huge.
And hopefully you view yourself
as part of this mission
and part of this community.
For anyone out there make sure that,
there's other parents like Heather
who could benefit from
this, and their children
could benefit, but there's
still an awful lot of people
who don't know about Khan Academy.
Or maybe they heard about Khan Academy
and they think we're a
for profit organization.
They think, oh that's just
another one of those ed tech
companies that's trying to
get me on some five dollar
a month plan or something like that.
That is not who were are.
We are there to give you free access
to what we genuinely believe
are the best materials out there.
One of the logical fallacies
or emotional fallacies
we sometimes see is people
think they get something better
when they pay for it.
And sometimes some of
these for profit companies
are able to take advantage of that.
They're like, oh Khan Academy's free,
but we charge you 10 dollars a month,
so you must think it's better.
But do your research.
The number of efficacy
studies done on Khan Academy,
the level of transparency, our
ability to partner with folks
like the college board around the SAT.
If you objectively ask
knowledgeable people
in the field, compare the
Khan Academy resources
side by side with any of the things,
even some of these things cost
hundreds of dollars a year,
I think you'll find that
the Khan Academy resources
are deeper, more aligned
with learning science,
have much more efficacy research on it.
Look at the Khan Academy Kids material.
It's free, it's not commercial.
I challenge anyone to find
anything that costs money
that comes close to what the
team at Khan Academy Kids,
and I brag about them a little bit more,
because I can't claim that I did that,
other than they kind of
joined forces with us.
And I obviously helped fundraise for them
and make sure that we're
aligned from a pedagogical
and strategy point of view,
but they've been doing incredible stuff.
And obviously on the Khan
Academy, the core Khan Academy
where I am more involved
and many, many other people
are involved, I can't tell
you how much work is put in
to make sure it's aligned
with learning science,
make sure it's aligned to standards,
and then do efficacy research on it
and make sure we're impacting
as many students as possible.
So more questions from AMA
questions, ask me anything
questions from YouTube.
Matius Ishimoto says,
and I'm reading these,
so I don't know what this is about to say.
Hi Sal, I wanna thank you and the board
for bringing Khan Academy to Brazil.
Can you explain why you
guys selected our country
and your expectations for the future?
So, great question, Matius.
It's interesting, in the
early days of Khan Academy,
obviously we've always had
this mission statement:
free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
And part of that vision is
we wanna make this available
to everyone on the planet.
Localized, not just the videos,
but the software platform,
the teacher tools.
When we got our first funding in 2010,
it was from the Gates
Foundation and Google.org.
And the Google aspect of the fund,
they said they wanted
us to start translating
this into the languages of the world.
So that's when we started back in 2010.
And then I believe it was 2012,
we had this gentleman
visit our offices out here
in Mountain View from Brazil
by the name of Jorge Paulo Lemann.
And our offices, even now,
our offices aren't fancy
by any stretch of the
imagination, but back then,
my office was above a Chinese tea shop
in downtown Mountain
View and it was kind of,
you know, one of our first
funders walked in and said,
Sal, this is not a healthy
working environment.
She sent some painters and
handymen to just make it
a vaguely decent environment.
But Jorge Paulo visited that office.
And if you're from Brazil,
you might have heard
of Jorge Paulo.
I'm ashamed to say that I
didn't know about Jorge Paulo.
But he's actually one of
the biggest philanthropists
in Brazil, and he and
his team came and said,
we need to bring Khan Academy
to Brazil as soon as possible.
And we were a five person
organization at the time.
We were like, oh, well, we don't know how
we're gonna be able to do that.
And they're like, we can
support Khan Academy.
We can help support the efforts in Brazil.
And so the Lemann Foundation,
named after Jorge Paulo
Lemann, they helped support
Khan Academy proper, and since
then have been great donors
and supporters of us.
But they've also, we've been
able to partner with them
in Brazil to localize the work
into Brazilian Portuguese,
align it with the Brazilian
national common core,
do efficacy and research
studies in Brazilian schools.
There's even a soap opera
episode in Brazil I heard,
where the protagonist ran a
fundraiser for Khan Academy.
So we have a lot of good
connections to Brazil.
I visited there and had a wonderful time.
I actually brought my whole family there.
And worked with the Lemann folks.
So that's what really
pulled us in to Brazil.
So we have 45 translation
projects around the world.
Most of it's volunteers
who are able to do it
in their own languages.
And they're unpaid, and your donations
are allowing us to build a platform
so that they can do it.
But there's several
geographies that we're able
to go deeper.
Brazil is one of them, India's another,
and then Spanish speaking Latin America,
especially places like Peru and Mexico.
We have partners, Carlos
Slim Foundation in Mexico.
And Carlos Rodriguez-Pastor
and his foundation in Peru.
And Tata Trusts in India.
These are all foundations
that have allowed us
to go deeper.
But I do wanna make it clear.
All of these groups
have each been donating
a lot of resources to make this happen,
but for all of us to reach, literally
the hundreds of millions of billions,
we need more resources.
And so it's a real
partnership with both large
philanthropian foundations
and small philanthropists
and people who can give,
even that $20, that $10.
Or even those three dollars.
It all makes a huge difference.
A question from YouTube, Emmanuel Sowitz
asks, how important do
you think coding will be
for children's education in the future?
I'm a big coding fan.
My background in undergrad, I
was a computer science major.
I always got a lot of joy out of coding.
Coding empowered me to build
the first versions of Khan Academy.
Khan Academy wouldn't
exist if I didn't have
some of those early desires
to prototype with coding.
And so it can be a very,
very valuable skill.
That's why we've invested on Khan Academy
on our coding platform where
kids, and I encourage anyone,
anyone who thinks that
coding is not for them,
go to Khan Academy and
try our coding platform.
You're gonna see that it focuses
on the creative side of coding.
You get to make pictures and animations,
literally within minutes.
But it takes you all the way down the path
so that you can actually understand
fairly sophisticated ideas
in computer programming
and computer science.
And so I think there's two tracks.
I think there's a lot of the
need for software engineers,
computer programmers,
it's only gonna increase.
There's so many industries
that are going to leverage
things like computing and data analytics,
and data science, and
artificial intelligence
more than they are today.
So there's just gonna be more
and more, and more jobs there.
So it's valuable for that.
But even if someone isn't going to become
a computer programmer, if
you're gonna become a doctor.
If you're gonna become a lawyer.
Whatever field, accountant.
Whatever field someone goes in,
almost every one of those industries
are going to be affected
by computing going forward.
So it's valuable to have at
least a baseline understanding
of what computers can do,
how computing logic works.
So that you can navigate
whatever field you go in to
in the future.
I'll also add that what's
fun about programming
and computing is it helps
build a certain form
of critical thinking and logic,
which is, I think valuable in every field.
So big picture, your
three Rs, so to speak,
which were never Rs, three
Rs with two Rs and an A.
Reading, writing, and arithmetic.
Those are always going to be super core
and there's going to be super
core for the 21st century.
But I think computing builds
a lot of those same skills
that the mathematics does in
terms of the critical thinking.
And there's a creation side to it too,
this engineering side
which is super valuable.
If kids can get exposed to
it, I would love to see it
and that's why we have
that on Khan Academy.
We also have APCS principles
which is an advanced
placement course which
is designed to be broad
so that a lot of people
might want to take it.
So you can go on to
Khan Academy right now.
You could either learn to
program on our coding platform.
Or you go to APCS principles
and I think almost anyone
watching this could engage on it.
Not only does it do the basics of coding,
it's how do computers work,
how does the internet work.
What is internet security?
All of these things you
are always hearing about,
we make available on Khan Academy.
I definitely recommend
taking a look at some of that
work as well.
Let's see, there a testimonial
from AJ, who's a student.
AJ wrote to us and says, no joke.
The only reason I graduated college
was because of Khan Academy.
I pledged to myself that if I graduated,
I would give every year after I graduated.
I have kept that promise and
I am giving a little bit more
during the COVID pandemic
because I want to make sure
that everyone has the
opportunity to learn.
Well AJ, thank you so much.
That means a ton to us.
I know, especially for
a young professional,
you're out of college.
You probably don't have a lot of money,
but whatever you can donate
makes a big different.
You know it makes a
different on two levels.
The money obviously allows us to do work,
allows us to hire people,
pay our server costs.
Our server costs alone are
several million dollars a year.
But also just that show of confidence.
I can't tell you, that positive
energy that you send our way
by supporting this makes a
big different to us as well.
It energizes me and I know
it energizes the team.
And it sets a very powerful example
for hopefully other people to help donate
to this cause that we think can empower
billions of folks over generations.
From YouTube, Life Fan asks,
Sal, if you have one million
dollars, what will you do with it?
And I'm assuming the
question is if Khan Academy
had a million dollars.
If I had a million dollars
I might think about
donating it to Khan Academy.
I'll answer your question.
I'll go on a little tangent.
A lot of people said,
Sal, how come Khan Academy
isn't a for profit company?
And I went through that thought process
in the early days.
Before I actually even talked
to any philanthropists,
I live in the middle of Silicon Valley.
Some of my friends are
venture capitalists.
They offered, hey, I'll write
a $100,000 check right now.
You give me X percent and
then you can quit your day job
and we can turn Khan Academy
into the next billion dollar company.
And so you can imagine,
that was very tempting.
But when I went through
the thought process,
I was getting so much psychic
reward from folks like AJ
saying how it helped them, and I said,
well what if we had to
put a pay wall behind it?
Or what if when someone
wants to learn algebra
they had to watch an ad?
And there's something that just
doesn't feel good about it.
And I imagined what a
home run would look like
in the for profit world.
If it's a home run, it would
be a Google or a Facebook,
or an Apple.
And that's great.
I think all three of those organizations
do amazing work.
They all innovate in the
world in amazing ways.
But then I thought,
what would a home run be
in the not for profit world?
Well what if Khan Academy
could be that next
great institution like the Smithsonian
or the library system, or
the great universities?
And it could be accessible by literally
billions of people.
When I started this I didn't have kids.
Now I have three kids.
But I thought about my
grandkids and their kids.
What would they be more
proud of, of Khan Academy?
And what could keep Khan
Academy sticking to its vision
and it mission?
And in my old career as
a hedge fund analyst,
I saw how much the actions of a company
are dictated by who owns the company.
That you could have a
founder who wants to do
very altruistic things, but
as soon as the ownership
changes, it might go in a
completely different way,
especially if it's owned by
firms that are just out there
to maximize the buck.
So I said okay, if I
want Khan Academy to last
multiple generations, and
stay true to that mission,
and that mission is its true bottom line,
it's gotta be a not for profit.
And I went through the thought process.
Even if I were to start the next Google
and become a billionaire,
I would just wanna donate
that money to the effort
of education anyway.
So lemme just cut out the middle man.
And the benefit of a not for profit
is any excess, we don't
have any right now,
but if we were able to
not run at a deficit,
it's not taxed.
It would go towards a reserve.
And so I said, well why,
just cut to the chase.
Lemme just, if I can make a decent living
as a professor, and I have to say,
Khan Academy's board pays
me more than generously.
I feel like I'm the luckiest
person on the planet
that I get to be paid to do what I love.
Anything above what I need for that,
what those billions that could have been?
I'm much happier that we're able to create
an organization that has
impact for the broader world.
And I know many of the
employees on Khan Academy,
many of them are supporting this.
They could go.
Google is in the same town as we are.
Facebook is down the street.
Apple is a couple miles away.
Pretty much all of them,
if they were just optimizing for money,
could go to those places and get stock,
and probably double, their total comp,
or whatever they're looking at.
But they've all made the
decision that they want
to work on this mission.
So in a lot of ways,
they're also major donors
to this organization.
That was me going on a tangent,
but that's where I obviously
feel quite passionately
about the world needs something like this.
And I can't imagine something more,
I can't imagine being luckier
than being able to work
on a mission like this.
And now if the question
is what would Khan Academy
do with that incremental
million dollars, it is,
we wanna make sure that our
servers stay performant,
that when you go, it doesn't
take seconds to load up.
That it's a fast, great experience.
We're always looking at how do we improve
the user experience.
For this coming back to school,
we're looking at ways to maybe
do some quick diagnostics
and ways for students to build
their foundations quickly.
'Cause we know with a lot
of kids out of school,
they're gonna have a huge
variance in preparedness.
We would, every dollar, much
less every million dollars,
allows us to think about
adding more subject areas,
or improving the subject
areas that we already have.
So those are just a sample of the things
that we would do with every
incremental million dollars.
So more donors I just wanna thank.
So there's three people
donated anonymously, $140,
so thank you three anonymous people.
You know who you are.
And thank you for that.
Petko Carmochan donated on Facebook.
Thank you so much, Petko.
Sati Meta on Facebook wrote,
thank you for making this available.
It's amazing and my
eight year old loves it.
Well, tell your eight
year old to keep going,
and thank you Sati for that donation.
From YouTube, Michelle Pally.
Aloha, I'm assuming you're in Hawaii.
Just donated on your website.
Thank you so much.
I am a teacher and use it religiously
for students and myself.
Well, Michelle, two things.
Thank you for your donation
and I would say this no matter what,
because I love the work, I mean the work
that educators do is the ultimate work.
But especially given this is
Teacher Appreciation Week.
Thank you Michelle for
the work you do and Aloha.
I actually was in Florida
speaking at a teachers' conference
last year and I learned a lot about,
all of us non Hawaiians
know about the term Aloha,
hello, goodbye, but
there's this whole notion
of Aloha culture, which is
just how do you project love
towards others and that really touched me.
And so Aloha to you as well.
Another anonymous donation, 50 dollars.
You know who you are, thank you.
Nashawa Shtelabi on Facebook,
thank you for your donation.
And Nashawa wrote, thank
you for all your efforts.
I use Khan Academy to
teach my three children.
You are our pride and hope.
Oh thank you so much, that means a lot.
Keep up the great work.
Sarah Holderman, thank
you for your donation.
Every dollar matters
and it means a ton to
all of us at Khan Academy
that you're taking the trouble to donate.
I know a lot of you all,
there's financial stress
in the world.
There's a lot of causes that need help,
and they're all good, noble causes.
But I thank all of you
all for appreciating
that in this world right now education
is very, very central and the access to it
is very unequal.
And I think hopefully
those of you all watching
realize how powerful a
lever Khan Academy can be.
And how much scale it has.
As I said, we're the budget
of a large high school,
but we're able to reach
a good chunk of humanity.
And not just for this year,
but for generations to come.
It's almost hard for the mind to grasp.
But that's what gets us excited
and that's what gets us energized
to do the work that we need to do.
We have another donation
just came on Facebook.
Thank you so much, from anonymous.
You know who you are.
Maybe it's the same anonymous.
Maybe it's different anonymouses, I guess?
It looks like, unfortunately,
we're all out of time.
I will, actually, I'll
take one more question,
'cause I think this is very relevant.
From Facebook, Gary Willmont asks,
how would you describe the
company culture at Khan Academy,
how has COVID-19 affected it?
Well Gary, I'll tell you
something I told the team.
We now have our company meetings now,
as you can imagine, on Zoom.
And one thing that the
leadership at Khan Academy
has been telling all the team members
is this is a time that you
always have to take care
of yourself and your family
before you take care of others.
We have team members, myself included,
but I'm lucky.
I have my wife and my
mother-in-law, we're all in the same
house so we're able to
tag team with the kids.
But we have team members who
might be a single parent.
They have young children at home.
It's incredibly hard.
And in a time like that,
the last thing you need
is for your employer to say, hey,
I thought that thing that
you were gonna get done
was gonna get done by this afternoon.
Where is it?
So we made it very clear.
Some of our team members
are able to step up.
They maybe have a little more time.
And a lot of us are getting pulled
in a lot of directions,
and so we're saying, hey,
this is not a time that we're judging you.
We know that the people who
are drawn to this mission
are drawn to do the right thing.
And we wanna figure out
how we can support you
in any way, shape, or form that we can.
And what I've told, I
told this to the team
at Khan Academy yesterday.
We have these aspirations.
Very ambitious aspirations
for what we can do
in the broader world.
Let's educate a billion people.
Let's create an institution
so that parents,
teachers, students feel empowered
for hundreds of years to come.
But in order for that to
feel right for the users,
we have to have the right energy
inside of our organization.
If we're not energized,
if we're not passionate
about what we do, that lack of passion
is going to be carried on to the learners.
We shouldn't do anything unless
we genuinely care about it.
And so I emphasize with our team members
work should not be work
the way that a lot of
people think about it.
A lot of people always think about, oh,
my god, it's Monday morning.
I guess I gotta go to work.
I guess I gotta pay the bills.
Work is where you spend
eight hours, nine hours,
10 hours or more per day for
a good chunk of your life.
It should be a place that fills your soul.
It should be a place
that gives you meaning.
It should be a place that
makes you feel connected
with other people who are like-minded.
And that's my aspirations for Khan Academy
is that not only can we be, in some ways,
pioneers on what could
happen for the world,
but we could also show
examples of organizations
that believe in people that are human,
that are about filling your soul,
that aren't political in
all of the kind of notions
that you might be used
to or are stereotypical
in some corporate settings.
There can be a place where
you get the best out of people
because every human being
has a natural desire
to wanna help other people
and a natural desire to
have impact on the world
and tackle challenging
intellectual issues.
And I think that's what we
hope to do at Khan Academy.
So the culture I hope is, I believe to be,
is very collaborative.
I don't sense, really, politics,
which I sensed at other organizations
that I've worked in in my life.
Because as I said, people
could go other places
if they wanted to optimize
for income or titles.
But people are coming here
to optimize for impact.
And I think that just
creates a really, really
positive culture inside
of an organization.
I will now read, there's a last few folks
who have donated.
So another anonymous donation
on YouTube, five dollars, thank you.
As I said, every donation matters.
Neela Mookergi, local,
donated on Facebook.
Thank you so much, Neela.
I really, really appreciate that.
And the time went by fast.
I guess time goes by fast when you're,
I guess maybe I'm talking too much.
I just wanna say again,
thank you so much for all of
you who've donated in the past.
Thank you so much for all
of you who donated now.
This really makes a huge, huge difference
for so many learners around the world.
And it makes a huge
difference for our team
and our capacity to do the
work that we want to do,
and this is especially
true, now that we're in this
COVID crisis, and the world
needs things like Khan Academy
that much more.
So thank you for being
on this journey with us.
Tell everyone you know that we exist.
We want to be used by more people
so that we can grow our impact even more.
And stay safe, stay healthy,
and I will see you tomorrow,
where we're going to have,
actually, Angela Duckworth,
famous education researcher on things like
grit and resilience and
perseverance and a close friend
of mine as well, on our
homeroom live stream.
See you tomorrow.
- Hello, (speaking foreign language).
I like to use the schedule
provided by Khan Academy.
My day includes doing a
math lesson on Khan Academy.
Doing my homework on Google Classroom.
And doing a guided meditation on YouTube.
Thank you Khan Academy.